back here in the valley veterans are
getting free access to dental care
jeremy j ford visited sahara modern
dentistry near saharan decatur today
where workers participated in smile
generation survey
having teeth again
has given me a second chance on life a
partnership with local non-profits like
adopt a vet dress for success and the
freedom child foundation to name a few
we give a day of free dentistry to the
entire community dr tang owns sahara
modern dentistry and sees the impact of
this effort i was emotional this morning
just knowing how many people are here
supporting us and volunteering to give
back to the community veteran roger
barton came in to get a new set of
dentures and looks forward to a new look
i'm getting all my teeth pulled
so i within probably two or three weeks
i should have brand new teeth a free
treatment that will take a few hours yet
save him thousands as i almost went and
got my dentures taken care of it would
have been it probably would have been
about ten thousand dollars so i went
through the process of going through
adopt a vet dental to get the work done
and build his confidence i'm thrilled
because i can smile again and have teeth
to smile with it's about providing an
opportunity for people who would not
have it otherwise jeremy j ford 8 news
now
more than 25 patients got much-needed
dental care as part of today's event
completely free of charge